so hello strangeloop hello virtual
attendees hello stenographer uh hello
people from the future watching the
recording
i know you're all thinking artisanal
machine generated api libraries it
doesn't sound enough like click bait
but luckily there's an alternative title
how to become a compiler engineer in
three easy steps right so one is be a
software developer
two work on a project and three
pretend that whatever you're working on
is a compiler so that's what we're gonna
do in this talk um there's a problem
that you don't have to approach like
it's a compiler problem uh but you could
so we're going to sort of compare and
contrast what advantages there are to
each of those things
all right so
a cast of characters
uh there's me i'm richard uh what you
should know about me is that just
because i'm up here with a microphone on
stage doesn't necessarily mean i know
what i'm talking about i'm just a
software developer i've been working on
this particular project for two years
and i'm going to talk about it to you i
hope that something i say causes you to
think about things differently or see
things in a new light but you don't have
to agree for me to that with me for that
to happen um you can just think
everything that comes out of my mouth is
nonsense but you can still take away
insight from it so don't trust what i
say just because i'm up here on stage
be skeptical
those are my two dogs mozzarella and
gouda
and that's my employer stripe so
standard disclaimer applies i speak for
me
my views don't necessarily reflect those
of stripe
um
right so i'd love to tell you all about
stripe
but all you need to know for this talk
is that stripe has an api
uh i'd love to the details don't matter
too much um and so like a lot of web ipi
apis the basic premise is you send http
requests to stripe
like mozzarella here and then stripe
does cool things for you
so here's here's mozzarella he makes his
http request the stripe api gives him a
response
and things are great right
except mozzarella is not too pleased
with this he doesn't think that having
to manually construct http requests is
very user friendly he thinks you should
just be able to use an api by calling
methods in his favorite programming
language right
so towards that end
stripe provides seven api libraries
for ruby node php pythongo.net and java
that makes this happen i guess so here's
an example of what it's like to make
that same http request that mozzarella
was making in the previous slide in in
stripe php right and then you echo out
the id
um so mozzarella pretty pleased with
this
uh so so things are great from his
perspective
but from from my perspective these
libraries have to be maintained right
um so we these libraries are are 10
years old
uh or so and we've manually maintained
them for eight years
um
and this has its benefits right like if
you uh every time there's sort of like a
new release of stripe like there's a new
resource that's added or a new method um
like you have to release a new version
of every library right like you can look
here here's like a change log of all the
releases that we've done for one of our
libraries since uh since january of this
year right so there's there's 40 of them
it's quite a lot
uh
right
um
but you get you get good at this after
you've done it enough right so it
doesn't take as much time as you think
and it's a great way to become sort of
really familiar with the surface area
that your your users are actually using
so there are some sort of pluses to
maintaining libraries manually
um but
we decided that we wanted to generate
them right automatically and there's
there's several reasons for this one
reason um you know it saves developer
effort if you run a script to to create
the new version of the library after
your api has changed that's that's uh
changes you don't have to make
um but also sort of the the other
benefits that you might not think of as
it helps your library be consistent um
it helps enable sort of sweeping
improvements across the entire library
right like we
last year we released sort of like
typescript definitions for our stripe
node library and we released sort of
like an entirely new improved interface
for stripe php and those sort of
improvements
uh wouldn't have been possible if we
hadn't started generating our code
but our goals for generation are kind of
specific right it's not sort of enough
for us to generate
any api library that happens to you know
support the request that you can make to
stripe right like these libraries
existed uh for eight years um before we
started doing this we had thousands of
users using these libraries
and so what we wanted to do is generate
sort of the libraries that already
existed right uh we didn't want to you
know tell our users you know just just
start from scratch we have this new cool
generated library you know breaking
changes for you right that's not that's
not great
um
and
we also like another thing about the
manual libraries is you know the code
looks kind of like a human wrote it
right which is which is good in some
ways and bad in other ways like
when you generate code like computers
they don't mind writing code that is
full of repetition and lots of
boilerplate and stuff like that
but we sort of consider the source code
of our libraries to be a form of
documentation right like if you're using
this library and there's a problem it's
nice if the source code is readable and
looks like you know human-maintained
source code and makes sense and you can
sort of trace back your error to you
know
the part of the library that's giving
you the problem uh and file a useful bug
report right so
um
right so
because of those sort of requirements we
built our own tool for generating
libraries we call it api code gen we
started doing this in around 2019 the
history is a little complicated but just
here's a simplified version
it's written um
all right
my slides have stopped updating let's
let's see
there
okay we'll do it like that um
right so it's written in type javascript
and it generates more than just the code
for the libraries themselves it also
generates change logs examples in our
documentation
uh things like that but i'm going to
focus mostly on the client library code
itself today
so gouda gouda is very excited about
this he's definitely going to generate
his libraries for his squirrel chasing
api
so let's sort of dive in
all right so
one way that you might approach this
problem is to use what i call the
template approach right uh so the
template approach the the fundamental
idea of the template approach is that
the transformations should visually
resemble their output right like you've
got some data it goes into this template
and then the output looks a lot like the
template
right um so here's sort of an example
applied to the stripe libraries
this is the same sort of code that
mozzarella was writing before the
library code behind that
is uh is not on the slide it's on this
slide though all right
so
there's a class it has a method called
create
and above there you can see that there's
this template right like it looks a lot
like the the generated output and the
idea is that if you had sort of like
many definitions for many resources and
many methods you could plug this into
the same template and you know get all
the hundreds of resources and methods
that you need out right
so so problem solved right says gouda
and kind of
yes
right um so
templates are sort of a 100 viable
approach
right
um
so they have the advantage sort of that
they visually resemble the output so uh
it's
very easy to sort of see if you're
generating your code from a template
if you've got some output that you want
to change or that there's a problem you
can sort of see in the template where
the problematic output originates from
just by using your eyeballs and then
sort of trace that back uh to to its
origin so it's got kind of a
debuggability advantage right the other
advantage is it's approachable right
like lots of lots of developers have
heard of of templates
um if you've ever used a static site
generator templates will be very
familiar to you so it's very sort of
easy to get started with templates and
they're proven too right there's a
popular open source project called
swagger code gen which is kind of like
if you're generating api libraries for
the first time this is sort of where you
can start
um and they're a project they support
sort of like
hundreds of target languages or or at
least dozens right uh and and the goal
for that project was to be easy to
contribute to and sort of easy to extend
so you could add new language targets
right
um and so templates work really well for
them it's very easy to just sort of add
a new template and then add a new target
language and you can you know sort of
customize it to your liking too all
right so on this slide this is this is
sort of like i plugged a simplified sort
of stripe definition into swagger code
gen and this is what comes out
um so and this output isn't entirely
like it's perfectly fine right it's a
little sort of repetitive sort of
boilerplatey um but this is like before
any customizations have been done so
templates can can be successful just for
contrast here's here's sort of what our
tool produces it's a lot sort of more
succinct there's this nice little
request function that just it makes an
http request you know kind of easy to
read
but we could get probably close to this
if we if we used
the template approach
but
the template approach has some limits
right and the fundamental limit
is that
templates remove all structure right
templates produce strings and strings
are are just unstructured data
structures right they're hard to
manipulate uh you can't decompose them
you can't test them like once you've
rendered your data to a string
there's not much you can do with it
other than sort of like you know check
to see if it includes something
uh or or parse it again and then try and
get some more structured information
back to manipulate on that um
and that
so you know like we we wrote our api
code gen tool and initially we were
following this more template approach
right but we started to sort of have
some problems some difficulties some
sort of problems that we wanted to solve
weren't weren't easy to do with this
sort of approach so the alternative i
call the compiler approach and that just
discards the idea that the the
transformations need to resemble their
output
and the fundamental idea here is that
the transformation should take place on
some data structures that are carefully
designed to make those transformations
easy right
so i don't know i i've never really
worked on like a traditional compiler uh
but the lingo is intermediate
representations right like you parse
your source code you've got these
intermediate representations you know
maybe like one or multiple of them and
you've sort of picked those carefully so
that it's easy to do the optimizations
or transformations or analysis that you
need to do
um so let's do that for
oh dear all right
uh
okay
i've lost wi-fi
so let's let's debug that
all right so if i had my slides i would
be showing you sort of like the journey
to convert a template into this compiler
approach right so imagine if you will a
slide that contains a template
and the job of this template is to to
render go code right
and there's sort of a problem with the
go code right so the problem we're
trying to solve is that some methods
um
if you if you've seen kind of http uh
some methods will be like
they'll have an id in the path right and
when the user sort of calls the method
to uh to invoke sort of the path
um
uh you'll need to sort of interpolate
that idea id into the path in order to
send the correct request right
um and in go the way that you do that is
you call format dot s print f right you
give this you know
famous sort of printf format string and
then you pass the id to that and then
you get the interpolated um
path right
so
at the top of the file it's going to be
generated is a block of imports right
and that block of imports should include
the format module kind of if and only if
you actually use the format module to do
this sort of string interpolation right
um so how do you solve that problem
wi-fi welcome to try my hot spot okay
all right it may or may not serve you
yes i'm back excellent
yeah
all right
okay so kind of as as promised
um here's here's the code i was trying
to describe with my word picture right
sometimes we use the format library and
sometimes we don't right um so so how do
you do this with templates well you kind
of have to have code duplication right
like when you're rendering the imports
you have to detect whether you're going
to use kind of the format library later
and then you know when you're using the
format library you do the same
calculation right so this is this is you
know
an example to demonstrate this problem
um about how
uh
you sort of can't do
sequential logic right it would be it
would be kind of nice if we could just
sort of like render the body of the the
method that we're rendering
and then we could pass that into this
function that checks whether it uses a
particular import and then that is what
the logic that would use to calculate
the imports right
um so that's sort of like what's
demonstrated here there's this sort of
uses format module right and we can do
this with templates right like we render
one template and then we use a regex to
sort of search for format s printf but
this isn't that satisfying uh like i
don't think parsing things with regexes
is generally a good idea uh and and
mozzarella is not too pleased with this
right
um
yeah yeah he's he's very demanding right
um
so what we're going to do is we're going
to take this code and we're going to
convert it to the compiler approach as i
call it right so the first step we take
this this template right this is a
javascript function that uses just sort
of the javascript's built-in template
string interpolation
and we're going to split it up into kind
of many templates right like this
yes
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to take kind of the input into
each of these smaller templates
and we're going to define a type for
that right so we've got sort of five
different types one for the function
itself one for the parameters in the
function header one for this struct
initialization statement that occurs in
there
um
right yeah so we've got all those types
and then we're going to take those five
types and combine them into one big type
right uh so
it's called syntax here because this is
sort of like a syntax tree which you a
phrase you might think about if you're
if you work with compilers right so
welcome welcome to compiler land uh
we're gonna do one more modification to
the syntax tree we're going to kind of
like get rid of all the uh irrelevant
sort of stuff that each node
was just passing to its children before
but didn't use directly
and so now you can see like this type on
the right is a recursive data structure
it's it's a tree right like each sort of
node of syntax contains nodes of syntax
beneath it
um and then we're going to take kind of
the body of each of these templates and
combine them into one big sort of render
function right so it takes one of these
syntax nodes and converts it into a
string right and it needs to have a
bunch of if statements in it to handle
each of the cases
right
so now we can sort of solve the same
problem as we were solving before we've
got this calculate client func syntax
function which produces this syntax tree
which may or may not use
interpolation
and then we pass the result of that into
this calculate imports function which
traverses through the tree
and decides to calculate imports right
so this mozzarella is a little bit more
happy with this
and this should feel better than parsing
a template with a ragex like you would
you wouldn't do this but you would do
this right so what if we what do we lose
we lost kind of the visual simplicity of
templates right and the approachability
of it right
before you could just kind of use your
eyeballs to find out where things were
happening but now you really have to
sort of understand what this syntax tree
is how it's being used what its role is
right
but what do we gain
now structure is preserved right we can
produce our output in a sequence of
steps
and can perform further manipulations on
the output that we calculate
um and also it's kind of easier to test
i'm not going to go into this example
that much
but like in our code sort of before we
started moving to this compiler approach
versus the template approach we were
doing a lot of these this sort of
snapshot testing where we would just
render a template and compare the entire
example to the entire output right and
these these tests weren't that readable
they weren't that satisfying it was
sometimes sort of hard to work with them
um but then once we sort of switched to
this more compiler approach we could
write this
summarize function that you see you know
being used here and that sort of like
made it took the output winnowed it down
to sort of like the stuff we really
cared about and then we could write a
test that
asserted on that so the testing story is
a little better
right
um
so we're here
now we we've got the structure and we
can do a bunch of transformations on
that structure before we produce our
output
why not go here right where even before
we get to the syntax tree we do some
transformations right so that's that's
where we're going next
um but gouda's not too happy about how
this slide just says data on the
left-hand side right that's not very
specific what is data um so so data is
an api definition
and probably the most popular type of
open api or api definition is open api
which is what we use at stripe but this
could be anything
there's sort of other restful api
definitions thing like raml or api
blueprint this could be you know a
graphql definition or grpc or anything
in principle but i'm going to talk
specifically about open api since that's
kind of what i know
um so it was it used to be called
swagger now it's called open api it
embeds another standard called json
schema for defining data types
and it's pretty great it's got a large
ecosystem of tools built around it
um
so the thing about open api its goal is
to be a standard and it's great for
describing kind of any api but a common
mistake i've seen is that
you to use open api directly when you're
really only trying to build something
for a specific api right and i'm going
to demonstrate that sort of with an
example
so one thing that we do in the stripe
libraries is we provide pagination
helpers for list methods right or for
methods that return a list right
and you can see
you can see what it's like to use these
pagination helpers on the top and then
on the bottom the typescript definition
for a method that returns a list needs
to be a little bit different uh than
you know just sort of a regular method
so a question we're always asking is you
know does this method return a list
right and the way that you do this is
our responses have this little field
called object and if the object field is
equal to the string list or it's the
type that is always equal to the literal
string list then that method returns a
list so to ask this of an open api
operation you need to sort of traverse
into nine properties in order to get
kind of the information you're looking
for right
um and the reason for this is because
open api supports any open api right
like with the stripe api
successful responses are always 200
right their content type is always json
right they always have this object field
but that's not true in the general case
um so what we do is we the first thing
we do in our tool is we take open api
and we convert it into kind of this
bespoke data structure called stripe api
that's custom tailored for our needs
right
and it's a lot easier to ask the same
question with with our data structure
since we designed it better
um
right so there's sort of two hard things
about library generation right
recursion and case analysis i think we
can agree that recursion is kind of
tricky what do i mean by case analysis
well in the stripe api we've got kind of
all these special cases right uh we've
got your primitives which aren't that
special that's sort of what you expect
but we've got
uh for example the the paginated lists
that i told you about before we've got
this concept of expandable like
sometimes um you'll get a a response and
a field will be just an id but if you
pass sort of a special
uh parameter when you made the request
it'll be expanded into like the entire
object that corresponds to the id right
so when we're writing these libraries
like seven libraries we need to
sort of handle all these cases in order
to have correct output right
um so mozzarella once an example
uh right so here on the left this is a
field in our api that has um all right
so i'm i'm going to tell you about sort
of like a bug that we had right this is
this is an object that's returned from
the api the correct sort of typescript
definition would be
this thing you see on the top right
um but we do this thing where we
decompose kind of
uh our typescript definitions right we
want to give this inner type sort of its
own name right and our tool was was
doing something incorrectly right it was
uh like this should have been
this array but it was the thing that you
see on the bottom right and the the
reason for that
um
well it was recursion and and case
analysis
right uh so
we sort of had like two templates one
for the interface and then one for the
namespace and we weren't sort of
properly recursing on the element of the
array like we weren't doing any sort of
recursion at all right
uh and and you know
we'd sort of coded ourselves into a
corner right like i found the bug i
figured it out and i just really
couldn't see a path to fixing it without
sort of rewriting the whole thing right
um so can we can we make this easier
this sort of thing easier right is there
is there a type of data structure that
makes recursive case analysis easy turns
out there is
it's called many things it's called
algebraic data types or some types or
tagged unions or discriminated unions
these are all sort of essentially the
same language feature
and i learned about these through
hipster programming languages like like
haskell purescript elm and things like
that
but type javascript has them too
typescript and flow you can sort of
emulate them
here's kind of an example of how you do
this
i'm running well on time i'm not gonna
dwell too much on this i think this is
strange loop a lot of you probably use
hipster programming languages anyway uh
so i don't really need to preach to the
choir about tag unions being great
um
so here's here's sort of like an example
of the particular way that
converting to this tagged union data
structure helps us right so on the left
here's sort of json schema this is three
different data types in json schema
there's a string there's a nullable
string and then there's this enum and
somehow these are all strings right i'm
sure like there are reasons for this um
but it's not that useful for us when
we're generating our libraries right so
when we convert it to our own data
structure that we've carefully picked
we've made these into different cases
right we treat nullable as a different
case than a string or we treat an enum
as a different case than a string and
that um
that has some disadvantages right like
if you do this you can represent a
nullable nullable noble nullable string
which like
you know we're not doing a very good job
with sort of making invalid cases
unrepresentable uh if you will um but
like we're willing to sort of take this
trade off right
um so this is this is the example of the
the sort of entire
stripe type tagged union that we use and
you can see sort of each of these cases
that we care about is moved off into
sort of its own case and this
it kind of makes the code that you're
writing when you generate the library
kind of write itself right you you know
you have an operation that you want to
do on a type you just write a bunch of
if statements for each type and then
like if you need to do something
recursive you do that recursive thing
and uh it really makes it sort of easier
to proceed uh through the various cases
in a disciplined way
[Music]
right
um so now i would
i would
like to talk about sort of the artisanal
uh aspect of this right um so
as i said before kind of the motivation
for all this is that we wanted to
generate the libraries that already
existed right we wanted sort of a lot of
control over the output
and because we've converted it into
these specific data structures
it's very easy for us to manipulate it
in arbitrary ways and we've got this
thing called overrides that we use to
sort of make arbitrary transformations
on these data structures before we
render them to a string or before we do
kind of the code gen logic right
i'm going to skip this
skip all this
the visitor pattern is great if you
don't know what it is it makes sort of
writing recursive functions a lot easier
so that's sort of the theme of that
but i wanted to talk about overrides so
though i mentioned you know you might
override for backwards compatibility you
might override because in a particular
language there's a reserved word that
conflicts with the thing that code
generation might normally generate like
in stripe you can void an invoice like
void is a reserved word in some
languages and so you don't want a method
called void like we you might want to
rename it to void invoice or something
like that or just if cogen doesn't
support something yet you can sort of
write an override to buy you some time
or if there aren't kind of enough cases
that this appears in your api definition
for it to be worth
implementing the logic to generate you
can sort of write an override to to
patch over the problem um
there's two types of overrides
it's you sometimes you kind of want to
if you want your library to be
consistent
which often you do you will want to do
the override on the input into your code
generation logic right but sometimes in
order to preserve backwards compality
compatibility you want your library to
be inconsistent in in some way and so in
order to do this you kind of need to do
this on the syntax tree level and not
like the api definition level
all right i'm going to go to
the conclusion
right
so
what what can we kind of learn for this
and and what i want you to take away is
the question
are your data structures working for you
or do you even have data structures
right so for us our data structures kind
of weren't working for us right like we
were using open api which is this data
structure that's designed for the
general case but we weren't working with
the general case we were working with a
specific case so we got a lot of
benefits from converting it to a new
intermediate representation um and like
strings weren't working for us either
they weren't structured enough so we
sort of introduced a new intermediate uh
representation if you will to make our
problem work better for us so maybe like
in a previous life i was a web backend
developer right and and the way these
kind of work is
you know you take an http request which
is a very sort of similar unconstrained
data structure and then you convert it
to wait http requests again an http
request and then at the end of the day
you just call a bunch of methods on your
models and anything can happen right
so if you're a web developer maybe maybe
there's some of you here maybe are there
some hidden intermediate representations
here that would make sort of the
operations that you need to do easier uh
you tell me right
um so whatever your domain is and you
know there's a lot of talks here at
strange loop where there i want you to
pay attention to kind of the data
structures that the people in the talks
are are working with like how has their
choice of data structure made the
problem that we're working on a little
bit easier
so thank you
i am just one of many engineers working
on this project that i've described at
stripe
uh there are many others
um and if you want to work on this my
team is hiring uh there's some some
contact information here
um
so yeah that's an option uh thank you
very much uh very honored to be here
thanks for being a great audience and
very patient
[Applause]
[Music]
you